[Música]
hablamos de salud en directo américa por
supuesto está con nosotros son más
romeros a la mar vamos a hablar de las
consecuencias del alcohol en nuestra
salud porque en españa se propuso
eliminar las bebidas alcohólicas en las
ofertas de los menús en restaurantes mar
y también pues vamos a destrozar todos
esos mitos y vamos a ver las realidades
de una copita de vino dos copitas vino
oa lo mejor también la cerveza que
supuestamente fortalece los huesos por
favor no me hagan triste ser porque
viene el fin de semana yo sí quiero mi
copita de vino la verdad lo lamento un
poco porque no vengo con buenas noticias
si estabas pensando tener un fin de
semana de fiesta además de esta
propuesta que decías de españa fue tuvo
una fuerte política porque ya sabes como
son erróneos si nos quitan pues ese vino
y esa cerveza en los almuerzos nos
ponemos un poco tristes pero bueno vamos
a aprovechar esta está propuesta de ley
que además al final no pasó para saber
qué ocurre cuando nos tomamos este
alcohol no desde un lugar moralista a
raúl no te preocupes sino que al menos
para tomar decisiones informadas las
consecuencias del alcohol sobre la salud
son amplios vamos a empezar repasando
las para empezar recordad qué es una
sustancia psicoactiva que puede llegar a
ser adictiva entonces qué es quieras o
no siempre nos vamos a exponer a ese
riesgo cuando consumimos alcohol porque
no están esclarecidos bien todavía las
dinámicas que hacen que una persona
pueda caer o no en la adicción más allá
de factores sociales segundo el alcohol
es un inmunosupresor por lo tanto
también tenerlo en cuenta cuando
decidamos consumir o no nos va a bajar
las defensas tercero por supuesto causa
enfermedades hepáticas sobre todo si se
consume en exceso y por último uno de
los mensajes más claros que queríamos de
dejar el alcohol es considerado un
cancerígeno es el tercer factor
modificable el primero siendo el tabaco
que provoca cáncer se atribuye por
ejemplo el 10 por ciento de todos los
casos de cáncer en europa a los hombres
el 3% en europa entonces importante
tener esa información clara recogimos
algunas cifras de españa' por ejemplo
pues para como
y poder comparar qué sucede ahí y poder
extrapolar lo también a otros países no
las muertes atribuibles al alcohol por
rangos de edad vemos que es el 8 por
ciento de todas las muertes entre el 15
y el 30 y los 34 años el 10% el rango
más alto está entre los 35 y los 54 y va
disminuyendo sobre todo a partir de los
75 años también pues por factores
sociales que hacen que también baje el
consumo de alcohol quede aburrido con
estos datos que usted dio y pues
obviamente a reducir por nuestra salud
el consumo de alcohol mar pero por eso
le quería preguntar también si estas
consecuencias sobre la salud se
mantienen también con un consumo
moderado pues de hecho para resolver esa
pregunta porque se dice mucho no un
consumo moderado no tiene riesgo
entrevistamos a la nutricionista e
investigadora en hábitos de salud de
vida saludable magda gamba escuchemos la
con lo que estamos viendo hoy en día del
a nivel ya que lleva a entender que el
alcohol no trae ningún beneficio para la
salud pues es evidente que tenemos que
dejar este mensaje de hablar de un
consumo de manera a decir ningún consumo
de alcohol
a no es adecuado para el ser humano por
supuesto hay una proporcionalidad no es
lo mismo consumir una copa al día que es
lo que se conocía como consumo moderado
hasta ahora que consumir más de esa
cantidad el riesgo es proporcional al
consumo que se tenga pero pues vamos a
dejar ese mensaje no existe un riesgo
cero yo sigo insistiendo y también me
voy por vencido es cierta esto que dicen
que el vino de forma moderada es bueno
para la salud pues una de las de los
mitos más extendidos y estoy segura que
somos muchos los que querríamos creer
que es verdad es que marc yo soy también
lo digo porque algunos doctores dicen
que si es bueno bueno es porque no hay
un consenso todavía en los estudios
científicos y por eso también vamos a
tratar de aclararlo hoy por ejemplo hace
20 30 años subieron los estudios de la
que se llamaba paradoja de francia que
concluyeron que la gente por beber vino
de forma moderada tenía menos
enfermedades cardiovasculares esa idea
ha quedado en el imaginario colectivo
cuando en realidad estos estudios
podrían tener muchos sesgos que no
tienen que no tienen en cuenta por
ejemplo los hábitos de vida otros tipos
de hábitos la vida saludable
el poder adquisitivo si la gente que no
beba alcohol era porque tenía problemas
de salud previos entonces todo eso que
se puedan sesgar esos resultados además
también es importante tener en cuenta
que la industria ha financiado muchos de
estos estudios recogimos por ejemplo
algunos de los mitos más extendidos
todos por ejemplo tienen que ver con la
salud cardiovascular pero es que incluso
tienen que ver con que previenen
enfermedades neurodegenerativas y esto
se atribuye sobre todo a un intocable a
un antioxidante perdón que tienen las
uvas que se llama reserva troll por eso
también volvemos a preguntar a nuestra
experta si el vino tiene resveratrol
pero los estudios donde se habla mucho
del resveratrol como antioxidante y con
beneficios para la salud se han
realizado principalmente en cultivos
celulares o en ratas
y cuando vamos a pasar esos resultados
aparentemente positivos al ser humano
tenemos que hacer otra gran cantidad de
investigación muy diferente con métodos
diferentes para decir lo que vimos en
las células lo que vimos en las ratas
también ocurre en el ser humano a ese
punto no hemos llegado y es muy complejo
y es muy lento llegar a esta conclusión
entonces raúl si queremos tener este
antioxidante más práctico comer las uvas
que no tomar el alcohol no me regañe
marc pero yo si me quedo con el vinito
mar y vamos a pasar entonces a ayudar en
nuestra segunda invitada el día de lujo
la hora reservo aquí en france 24